tada
23 kilos four weeks to build and depicts
Charles in the ceremonial uniform he's
expected to wear on the 6th of May it's
made up of many different chocolates
including Twix Milky Way and a Galaxy
and the chocolatier Master chocolatier
who put it all together Lindsey Clark is
here tell me quickly about what tell me
about I love the medals yeah we've had
lots of fun using all their individual
celebration chocolates
to create the different medals from a
cross-section of the bounty look can we
have a close-up of the medals and then
we can talk about them
so we start with the the main piece
that's a cross-section the Bounty we've
got malteser Twix let's do it slowly
maltesers Twix fancy a bounty chocolate
Galaxy yeah galaxy uh a Milky Way Milky
Way of course and uh Snickers I think at
the end Snickers at the end and what
about on his lapels the the epaulettes
we have I kept making that mistake sorry
we got yeah bounties and galaxies and
milky ways and Twix and you can see in
the collar which was the trickiest bit a
whole line of Milky Ways and the ends of
the maltesers which I've used up the the
ends that we cut to make the maltesers
yeah the bits you cut off you put around
the collar at the top that's right and
you
styled it on looking at hours and hours
of footage of it yeah that's right yeah
and uh and then from there made lots of
sketches and uh Tim Simpson the sculptor
created the head and Clay first so we
had to get that just right because
obviously everybody knows what Charles
looks like and we didn't want to get
that wrong and then created a mold and I
cast it in chocolate and then reused
um yeah nearly 17 liters of of melted
celebrating chocolates
uh well hopefully we're gonna share it
with everybody and uh and um so you're
going to take it along the Route on the
day or who you're sharing it with it
we're not quite sure yet but I think I
think they've got lots of people to show
it to you first yeah and is it solid
this is solid okay solid you're not
saying our King's an airhead are you
well there is a little bit of it brim to
breathe exactly amazing how much you
think it's worth
no idea oh Priceless yeah to me and I
know it was an absolute schlep but my
goodness mate absolutely lots of people
want to take their pictures with it
already today thanks a lot